okay the more I look into this
the more fishy it is and it just seems a bit tone deaf
and it absolutely is really tone deaf
and I wanna break it down
Wanna break down why
the way that this film is being promoted is harming survivors
why survivors feel betrayed by it
and why this actual conversation
and the way that the dialogue around this is playing out is actually
kind of a good thing so I'm Doctor Zoe
I have a PhD in feminism
specifically looking at social media and why survivors share their stories
so firstly this film is based on a romance novel
this is predominantly it's a fiction book
it might be still based on some true elements from the author's life
but it is a fiction book and fiction is so important for survivors
and I'll tell you why sometimes
survivors come across books and stories
and TV shows and movies
that really speak to the nuances
and specifics of their domestic violence experience
and the thing about experiencing domestic violence or an abusive relationship
is that one of the key
commonalities between people's experiences is a feeling of isolation
they feel alone
they feel like no one understands what they've been going through
they feel completely debilitatingly alone
and then
they stumble across a text that seems to just explain exactly what has happened
and in a way like fiction can do this
in a way that looking up information about what might be happening to you can't
um I've had this experience myself as a survivor where I've read books
I've just gone oh my God
like that just spoke to me
and I know that I have not read this book
but I know that people who have feel that this book really spoke to them
and was able to touch them
because it deals in quite a nuanced way also
I hear um
with themes of domestic violence
okay and this is key
but moving on to the way that the film has been promoted
Blake Lively has been promoting it like a brand
she has got a brand for it
the florals she's saying wear your florals and bring your girlfriend
and then people have seen her also promoting her own personal hair products
and things like that um
as well as just using a tone that's very bubbly
and light hearted and fun throughout
along with lots of cookie cutter responses to questions about domestic violence
and the film's content but it's not working
and it's not working because we are all too media literate for this
these days
you cannot control the narrative the way you wanna control the narrative
because we know too much and we
people see people know
people go oh
you're promoting a personal hair care brand
are you leveraging off of a really
you know meaningful film with lots of dark themes
to promote something like your hair care product
to make personal to grow your personal wealth because we're not okay with that
and we can see it and recognise it
and a few years ago
it might not have been picked up on and it might have been kind of accepted
and nowadays it's not
and I think what we're also saying is that Blake Lively has a comfort zone
and it does not extend to speaking about the nuances of domestic violence beyond
you are more than a survivor
you're more than that story
you are whatever you want it to be
and so what that tells us and audience who has graduated past Beyonce
putting the word feminist up on a screen behind her
we are in 2024 we're not in 2014 anymore
and her feminism is back there
so she's speaking in platitudes
she's using flowery language to describe these broad feministy feminine ideals
and it is not working on the audience that are too grown up for that
because we're not at Gossip Girl anymore
so she it feels like she's more comfortable with playing into the ROM com
playing into idea like this is a film about the nuances of being a woman
and women can be messy and women can be this and women can be that
and like we already know that and that's like really great
but like we need to go beyond that now for this conversation
but she seems much more comfortable staying in that zone
and staying in that zone of
this is a fun romcom so
it's starting to feel like she's trying to make the film more
frivolous than it actually is
and it makes you wonder if she had any briefing
or training around the fact that this is a domestic violence film
because like at my organization
we have that conversation with people
we say when they come to work with us
we say you're now working for this organization
so people are gonna wanna talk to you a lot more about domestic violence
and then we equip them with the skills they need to have those conversations
cause it's not just about doing it at work
it's about the fact that your life around work is also gonna change
and probably involve a lot more discussion about this difficult topic
so when we put all of this together
we can see that we have an actress here
who doesn't seem to wanna engage in the themes
and doesn't seem to understand the themes
and then we go okay
but she played the main character who was a victim survivor in this film
so did she properly engage with the character
and then we start to feel betrayed because we go
well this was a really important text
and a really important conversation about these things
this text really meant a lot to a lot of people
and it was also for those who didn't know the book already
it's an opportunity to engage with this kind of topic again
and to speak to a whole lot more survivors
and people start feeling betrayed
because they start feeling like the way that the actor engaged in the film
um engage in the content was inauthentic
and then we have a problem
because the last thing that a film wants is to be seen as inauthentic
people are feeling emotional
people are feeling and rightly so
and feeling betrayed by the way that this is coming across
so some people are saying well
it's just the actress she shouldn't be
have to be be expected to have like a DV professional level of knowledge
and that's fair but she should have been trained and she should be a little more
I guess on top of the fact that this is a really important conversation
and seeing this as an opportunity to rise to that occasion
and I think that it is absolutely valid that people feel betrayed by this
um kind of turn of events
and I think it's also a really
really good thing because what it shows is that we're at a level now
where we have a baseline level
understanding of DV and how it plays out
and we can hold people accountable to that level
we should and we can and it's absolutely okay to
and when we see people with huge platforms in Hollywood talking about this issue
and not doing it in a trauma informed way
not doing it in a survivor centric way
it is absolutely okay to hold them account and say do better
because next time there's a film about this
they'll look at this as a case study and hopefully they will do better